they invaded Congress and the Supreme
Court they ransacked the presidential
Palace behind me the demonstrators in
Brazil have been widely condemned but
why are they rioting and what is it they
want
the protesters are supporters of the
former president Joe bolzanaro and they
simply haven't ever accepted the result
of the election in November they've
co-opted the green and yellow of Brazil
and they've been out on the streets in
their thousands ever since but it's
interesting actually amongst their base
that's well documented evidence that
some of them have extremely extreme
views and a very right-wing tendency now
they've been outside military camps
across the country basically they're
calling for an intervention by the
military but in real terms that is a
coup these protesters absolutely despise
the left-wing politics of Lula de Silva
on Sunday they came out in their
thousands but many think that this was
an organized attack on Democracy in
Brazil
foreign
does have a fragile history of democracy
in the 60s and democratically elected
government was taken down by the Army
and the military ruled until 1985 so
people here do know that this type of
thing could happen I think it's fair to
say that the vast majority of people in
Brazil do support the results of this
election and Lula as the president but I
think many here are fearful that this is
going to become a continuous War of
Attrition of what they call domestic
terrorism
president Da Silva was sworn in on New
Year's Day He is said to be absolutely
furious at the events that took place
here he said to the Press he simply
can't believe that it has happened he's
also very angry with the police he said
they did not enough to stop people
getting into these various buildings
[Music]
he's promising a major investigation
into what happened here and the justice
department says a so far over 1500
bolsonaro supporters have been arrested
and are being held
[Music]
is actually in Florida he went there
before the inauguration ceremony however
he is now in hospital he was stabbed in
2018 so he is ongoing stomach problems
he has tweeted a condemnation of the
attack he said at least that the people
the protesters shouldn't have gone into
the buildings but he does continue uh to
espouse the theory that the election was
stolen from him and that's done nothing
to calm his supporters down here the
Brazilian government I think will want
to know and try to find out and the
investigator to be looking to see where
the bolsonaro uh his family and some of
his ex-government were actually involved
in what happened here now across the
world leaders have written and run the
president's expressing their support
amongst them Joe Biden who says he is
he's absolutely certain in his mind that
Lula de Silva won the election and that
he is the rightful elected president of
Brazil